[Applause]
oh look we must have done good okay
we're on overtime
uh here uh for Laura do you think
Merrick Garland is taking too long to
press criminal charges related to
January 6 will The Movement lose
momentum if he keeps stalling yes I
think the public perception and the
patience of the American public has a
shelf life of dairy and I think that
it's it's time to have more insight more
transparency and of course public
hearings on the Congressional side too
but he has done something that's true
but I think people want more given the
volume of people who are allowed to walk
out of the capital that day
and I I mean I saw that there was seven
hours missing on the call logs now they
the this January 6 committee looking
into the event of that day wanted Trump
to turn over his call records and he did
except for seven hours when all the [ __ ]
was going down it's it seems like this
is not the first time he is just
blatantly give you the slap in the face
and nothing happens that's I think what
people are upset about is something like
that can happen and it's so blatant and
then Merrick Garland as attorney general
maybe he's the new Robert Mueller you
know somebody we thought was going to be
a badass and it's just not working out I
mean I talk to people all the time who
uh are making the case that look maybe
Trump won't run again in 2024 because of
the legal proceedings against him uh and
this is what a lot of Americans are
asking themselves right now is that uh
are some of the actions that led up to
January 6 is actually going to result in
something that derails what looks to me
to be him coming back and winning the
Republican nomination in 2024. yeah you
think he's going to run and win I do too
I mean at least the nomination I mean he
does he he is faltering in some ways the
crowds and so forth but when the
campaign starts again and he starts
attacking the people who you know
challenge him I know some of the people
who I think are going to challenge him
for the Republican nomination I'm
obviously rooting hard for them like uh
I guess I got out that you know I'd have
to ask their their permission and all
that jazz um
can't be that big a circle
there are a number of people gearing up
to challenge Trump the Republican
nominations people that you have respect
for yes yeah I I call them sane
Republicans oh they know
there are many some somebody like there
are many that Larry Hogan and Maryland a
guy like that you're talking about I
like an Admire Larry Hogan a great deal
so that that'd be an example of someone
who I think could make a very very
strong case uh if the Republican primary
electorate is actually ready to hear
that case and move on from Trump right
now though uh Trump still has a very
very strong hold among the you know like
the most fervent party activists so but
you know but I do hear from Republicans
who are going to run against him they're
like hey maybe some legal action will
will come in and and uh you know take
Trump out or maybe Trump's actually just
posturing because he wants to keep
attention on him
um so this is one of the major variables
they suggest to me if something's going
to happen I agree with you it has to
happen soon I mean until if if there
were to ever be a criminal allegation
against Donald Trump until that happened
I think he remains Teflon Don to his
entire base I mean this is somebody who
within recent weeks has praised Vladimir
Putin as a genius and then wondered why
people thought about collusion and
Russia and then sued Hillary Clinton DNC
and others including James Comey for
having the audacity to say that he was
in favor of Russia and collusion I mean
I don't think this is somebody who views
any part of the justice department to
date as being truly threatening now
what's happening in New York and the
idea of the organization is children Etc
that might be something to raise enough
eyebrows among people but I think until
that happens why the concern is until
there is actual action taken he will be
able to say well aha there was no there
there whether it's true or not but I
think that the American people have to
realize that the Department of Justice
has taken action they have prosecuted
and much like we talk about how much the
race is staying for the notion of
Republicans catering to an audience of
one the doj does not cater to a
defendant prospectively of one there
were hundreds of people inside of that
Capital that day and there are other
crimes happening every single day and so
they have to balance the priorities of
those over being perceived as political
okay maybe I'm just naive but I heard
this is again with Trump I only go what
I actually have heard so we don't have
to talk about speculation what I know
like like when he said you know I I said
to Comey that this is a this is a hoax
I I or Russia if you're listening you
know the crimes that are committed right
I heard him on the tape say to the guy
in Georgia who counts the votes if you
could just find me
11 000 more
yeah
I'm not a lawyer but what
[Applause]
is that why I don't do your crimes out
loud you won't get caught
but maybe they're soft on crime bill you
know
I don't know why that itself take that
one out and you know you can't do that
remember bogdonna no no no no
didn't he promise like my old golf clubs
and I mean it was like it was like such
a lesser version of that
a thing of value okay uh
Republicans hold a 17 point Advantage
wow in voter enthusiasm
whoa
that to my point the last time the Gap
was this why Democrats lost more than 60
House Seats wouldn't a third party at
this point oh this is a t this is
probably this is for me thank you
somebody teed this one up for you I see
everybody at this point just hurt
Democrats oh no no and the left hook
came around right wouldn't the third
party hurt Democrats oh sorry you got
snookered there well so if you look at a
big picture our system is uniquely
vulnerable to authoritarianism because
you have this two-party system where one
parties that comes to terrible
leadership like Donald Trump then
everything falls uh under him if you
look at other countries around the world
UK has five parties Germany has seven
parties Sweden has eight parties and
then if one party loses its mind the
system goes on it's not an existential
threat so the question is how do you get
from a two-party system that by the way
is getting more polarized more
dysfunctional more people are getting
fed up and the reason why so many
Democrats ads are unenthused is that
they came out and were told look you get
Trump out then all these great things
will happen and then as their lives have
stayed the same or in some cases gotten
worse than they were saying why do you
want me to come out again in 22 why do
you want me to come out in 24 you can't
make every election existential and
fear-based or else eventually your
voters start to tune out right okay you
were great I did want to mention that my
podcast which has only been out for less
than two weeks went to number one on the
after I don't know so I want to thank
the people who are like listening to
this thing it's not like this show it's
not political but I guess it's fun to
people so thank you and it's out there
all right thank you everybody you're a
great crowd